for companies and consumers 2015 was a
big year for practical design what do I
mean by that
think of it this way it is no longer
enough that our devices be smart we want
them to be useful more than that we want
them to be usable intelligence is
flashing usefulness and usability those
are substantive good practical design is
where those three qualities intersect
these are important distinctions and if
you're a designer you probably make them
all the time but this year saw these
concepts first into the public
consciousness in a big way just look at
smartwatches whether you hate them or
love them is actually irrelevant because
what matters is this if you've used one
even briefly you probably have some
strong opinions on its user interface
and that's exciting rarely has society
been more attuned to so fundamental a
design concept as a user interface and
that attention extends way beyond
wearables this year's biggest upgrades
to Android and iOS and talking about
things like now on tap and 3d touch
these are all geared towards making our
devices simpler to navigate major
progress in speech recognition mobile
connectivity and neural networks have
all legs for rapid advances in the
utility of apps and the usefulness of
our digital assistance between us
distribution in the New York Times and
the support has been getting from
cinematographers and app designers and
game developers even VR has gotten less
intimidating across the board consumers
are demanding less and less friction
from their everyday interactions and
designers are responding by honing our
technologies to finer and more
functional points
you